I can actually talk more about jQuery.
It is a DOM manipulation library.
By DOM manipulation library I mean that
it traverses through your HTML elements.
So it's going to help
you handle the events
taking place within your HTML elements.
It's very fast.
It's a JavaScript.
It's completely coded in JavaScript.
And yeah, you can use it for
a lot of your projects
where you want to change
content within your HTML
elements directly through
a function rather than
going to your HTML page and
hard coding values into it.
This dynamically changes how-
>> How would I go on jQuery?
>> Okay, yeah,
we can actually look at that.
So yeah, here are what I've done is,
I've opened up jQuery.js in Sublime.
So, this is going to be
your JavaScript library.
Instead, [CROSSTALK] yeah we've already
given this file to you in advance.
And this is helper.js which
is also provided to you.
So helper.js has a bunch of
variables that map to HTML elements.
Like for example,
with helper.html header name.
It contained the header tag
h1 with the ID name and
you've put in some data inside.
This is all populated from JSON.
So wherever you have the percentage
data is populated from a JSON object.
>> Okay.
>> So that's what we are doing here.
So these variables help
you map to the HTML form,
it's designing your HTML webpage.
Okay, when you see this bit
of code right here down here,
you can see
the $document.readyfunction().
So the dollar symbols of the notes with
jQuery produce jQuery class.
Yes, so when you see,
when you take this particular
line $ in braces,
you have a button.click.
What you are defining is any
element with the name button.
So we have one button in our
resume in our HTML page.
>> Okay.
>> And so it's going to pick that button
element and it's going to define
a click event handler on it.
>> And then the dollar sign is
telling me that it's jQuery?
>> That's right,
it's pointing to jQuery.